.
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE TO BE ABOUT
GOING FORWARD.
>> THANK FOR JOINING US.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THE MAJOR CRYPTO CURRENTLY
EXCHANGE HAS CHANCED AND
DECLARED BANKRUPTCY.
WHAT IS HAPPENED IS COMPLICATED.
LATER IN THE WEEK, TUCKER WILL
HAVE A FULL INVESTIGATION.
HERE'S WHAT WE KNOW FOR SURE.
SAM BANKMAN FRANK WAS THE SECOND
LARGEST DONOR TO DEMOCRATS,
SECOND ONLY TO GEORGE SOROS.
THAT MONEY BOUGHT BANKMAN FREED
A LOT OF ACCESS.
THE WASHINGTON FREEBIE CON SAID
THEY WERE AT THE WHITE HOUSE
CONSULTING ON CRYPTOCURRENCY
REGULATION.
AT THE SAME TIME, THEY DIDN'T
CARE ABOUT MONEY.
HE SHOT THIS PROMOTIONAL VIDEO.
>> THE GUY YOU SEE NEXT TO ME IS
THE MOST GENEROUS BILLIONAIRE IN
THE WORLD AND I FOUND HIM.
>> I'M SAM.
>> 29-YEAR-OLD GUY DONATED $50
MILLIO
MILLION.
NEXT YEAR HE'S PLANNING TO CO
NATE $50 MILLION A YEAR.
NEXT DECADE, HE WILL PROBABLY
GIVE AWAY MORE THAN $10 BILLION.
>> THE AMOUNT OF GOOD THAT YOU
CAN DO FOR THE FUTURE OF THE
WORLD IS REALLY LARGE.
IT'S MORE THAN YOU CAN DO TO
MAKE YOURSELF HAPPY.
>> HE'S FUNDING EVERYTHING YOU
CAN THINK OF.
GLOBAL WARMING.
>> ONE OF THE BIGGEST PROBLEMS
THAT WE HAVE TO TACKLE TOGETHER.
>> COVID-19 PREPAREDNESS.
>> WE HAVE TO BE READY FOR THE
NEXT PANDEMIC.
>> THERE'S A LOT OF SPECULATION
RIGHT NOW ABOUT THE CONNECTIONS
BETWEEN FTX AND UKRAINE.
TURNS OUT THAT FTX SET UP A
WEBSITE FOR USERS TO SEND CRABS
TO UKRAINE'S CENTRAL BANK.
THAT LED TO SPECULATION THAT THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT MIGHT HAVE SEND
TAXPAYER MONEY TO UKRAINE THAT
ENDED UP AT FTX AND DEMOCRATS.
WE'RE JOINED BY MIRANDA DIVINE.
SHE'S A COLUMNIST FROM THE "NEW
YORK POST."
TELL US WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
>> LOOK, WHAT WE KNOW IS THIS IS
A -- CRYPTOCURRENCY IS
UNREGULATED.
SOMETHING THAT WARREN BUFFET
SAYS IS AN INDUSTRY OF
E
CHARLOTTIAN
CHARLOTTIANS.
HE SAYS IT'S SELLING WORTLESS
MATERIAL.
BASICALLY DIGITAL CURRENCY.
DOESN'T EXIST.
WE HAVE THIS KID THAT LIVES A
BIZARRE LIFESTYLE, SLEEPS ON A
BEAN BAG WHEN HE'S NOT LIVING IN
A POLYCULE, WHICH IS LIKE A
SEXUAL RELATIONSHIP WITH A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE.
HE SOMEHOW BECAME THE YOUNGEST
BILLIONAIRE IN THE WORLD, WORTH
UP TO $20 BILLION AT ONE POINT.
HE WAS SHUFFLING THIS PRETEND
MONEY AROUND IS THE PLACE AND ON
THE COVER OF FORTUNE AND FORBES.
AS YOU SAY, HE WAS THE SECOND
BIGGEST DONOR TO THE DEMOCRATS
FOR THE MID-TERMS AND HE ALSO
DONATED $10 MILLION TO JOE BIDEN
IN 2020 TO BECOME PRESIDENT.
HE FREQUENTLY WENT TO THE WHITE
HOUSE AND WAS REALLY IN THE
BOSOM OF THE LEFT.
AS YOU SEE, HE WAS INDULGING IN
ALL SORTS OF WOKE CAUSES
INCLUDING UKRAINE.
WHY ON EARTH THE AMERICAN
TAXPAYER IS FUNNELING TENS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OVER TO
UKRAINE SO THAT THEY CAN FIGHT
RUSSIA AND WHY ON EARTH THEY
WOULD BE INVOLVED THE UKRAINIAN
GOVERNMENT WITH THIS COLLAPSED
CRYPTO CURRENTSY EXCHANGE WE
NEED TO KNOW.
I'M SURE WHEN THE BANKRUPTCY
TRUSTIES COME OUT WITH THEIR
INFORMATION, WE'LL FIND OUT
MORE.
IT'S NOT ENOUGH FOR THE MINISTER
OF DIGITAL TRANSFORMATION OF
UKRAINE TO JUST SCOFF AT
QUESTIONS WITH A COUNTRY AT WAR
DABBLING WITH CRYPTOCURRENCY
WHICH EVERYBODY KNOWS IS SHADY.
>> THANKS, MIRANDA.
THERE'S SO MANY QUESTIONS HERE.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO SEEING
TUCKER'S PIECE ON THIS.
CERTAINL